what do you got there an edible you want
to give it to him
you think i'm going to take food from a
stranger
you say cher this dude's got a lollipop
for you
who makes that roofie um
[Laughter]
lollies by roofie we got weed smokers in
here tonight
no are you an edible guy or is that just
for me
well they're yours they're yours are you
make them
you made that lollipop let me see that
you first of all man it's
if you gave me a million dollars and
you're like go make a lollipop i'd be
like
wow now how many milligrams are in each
one of these
how would i know that yeah
i can't wait to dig into these i guess
[Applause]
how many milligrams i don't [ __ ] i'm
not eating them i don't know
this is by the way this is this is old
school
before there were stores this is old
school edibles
remember when you could eat half of a
brownie you're like i'm not high and the
other person you ate the other half is
like
[ __ ] up
[Laughter]
remember when the edibles were just
started you had no idea where the weed
went
in the pan you're like i have eight and
12 cookies i'm not high
i ain't one i'm gonna die like you know
what i mean
[Applause]
[Music]
so you don't know
okay do you know how much weed you used
eight ounces and in what type of weed
eight ounces in a gallon of honey
that sounds like a clint eastwood movie
clint eastwood in eight ounces and a
gallon of honey
oh you got the honey too is there weed
in the honey
okay
now now now let me ask you another
question and then we'll get on to the
show
uh what what do these taste like
california it tastes like california
can you describe that for me
[Applause]
did you see what she did i would
describe that and she went
which is right we're in california what
what do these taste like
watermelon okay
and this this tastes like honey
[Music]
look i feel like you'd be disappointed
in me if i didn't
i mean it doesn't bode well that i can't
open it up
why
now listen
i will tell you like this the reason i'm
going to eat this particular can
is because i'm a textured texture guy
when i eat
you know what i mean some foods that i
like the way they taste but the texture
like uh like man
like you if i bite into a brown part of
a banana
it is [ __ ]
over for me but this is i will see what
the deal is with the texture on this
because what are those what are those
halloween candies that like are in the
shape of like an
orange slice
no not candy corn but the worst the
worst
the worst halloween candy is that
[ __ ] peanut
butter oh that [ __ ] peanut whatever
that [ __ ] thing is
you give me a peanut i am [ __ ] in
your mailbox that's what's happening
oh yeah that was a nice candy all right
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well i have to tell you
there's definitely weed in that
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know if it's in all of them but
it's in that [ __ ] one for sure
god sam i'm gonna tell you because i
just ate
a little pill that was just gonna get me
going a nice little pill and that was
just 50 milligrams
just to have fun on stage but
no no it's not really that much when you
take them every day
but that one really tasted like that got
dipped in the sauce you know what i mean
[Applause]
yeah we'll see what happens everybody i
might end up sitting down there with you
[Applause]
you want one
let's just lock the doors and get [ __ ]
[Applause]
up
[Music]
[Music]
you